يحاول فرق الدفاع المدني السوري الوصول
الى اخر الضحايا في هذا البناء يبدو انهم
استطاعوا انتشال احد ما ولا ادري اذا كان
على قيد الحياه او اذا كان قد فارق الحياه
يبدو انه قد فارق الحياه لانهم قاموا بوضع
قاموا بوضعه بكيس من اكياس الموتى بعد
ساعات من العمل
ولثلاثه ايام اليوم هو اليوم الثالث
استطاع الدفاع المدني السوري
انتشال جميع الضحايا من هذا الموقع في
بلده عزمارين قربى الحدود السوريه التركيه
قاموا بانتشال اكثر من 20 شخص من هذا
الموقع
وانهو العمل وانهو العمل بشكل كامل في هذا
ما تزال ما تزال هناك عده مواقع اخرى في
بلده عزمارين تعمل فيها فرق الدفاع المدني
على انتشار العديد من الضحايا صهيب خلف
الجزيره
ريفو ادلب الحدود السوريه التركيه